are we going to have an election where
even you know where where you the votes
come through there are some legal
battles but ultimately they count and
we're like that that's it or is it going
to be a dispute where everyone's
fighting and arguing in the streets I
think that's what it is
I lean towards uh your line of thinking
so there will be an election is what I'm
saying the votes will be counted and
then just like 2020 there is going to be
widespread dispute here's why I don't
think there's gonna be people in the
streets because there weren't people in
the streets during covet
a lot of these the lockdowns and the and
the pushback was far less than if you
had set us all down I think everyone in
this room and it was 2019 and you said
all right if these state governments are
going to make it that you're not allowed
to leave your house for two weeks for
basically for a lot what a lot of people
think is no reason are the American
people gonna stand for this or is there
going to be violence we would have all
said they're never going to be able to
get away with it but they did so I I
disagree okay let me hear you so why did
people Riot like crazy all over the
country we we Joe we call it the 529
Insurrection now on the surface the
media says black lives matter but as
we've discussed in great detail the real
reason people in New York were rampaging
through the streets was because they
were locked inside and they had gone
insane and then their anger was directed
towards some random cause so you had the
famous story where a guy calls 9-1-1
after people were ransacking his
building ransacking his apartment
building had nothing to do with BLM he
called the police said they're breaking
into my building what do I do and they
said sir the city is under attack what
would you have us do
on the surface everybody said it was BLM
but the real anger that was within
people was because they had been
isolated they were getting pain sickly
from lack of vitamin D malnourishment
and then a catalyst sparked it off and
they went nuts Tim I don't think there
was as much anti-covet pushback in the
anti-covet populations and areas as I
would have expected in 2019. I agree
that's all I'm saying I agree with the
idea that Republicans and conservatives
who were complaining didn't do anything
else that's all I'm saying I believe the
real reason for the mass unrest was not
George Floyd that was just a spark to
give an excuse to people who are losing
their mind I don't think things about it
though they bust in people and paid them
left piles and pallets of bricks and
stuff they brought in their operatives
and took it
it is true because it was all over the
news they'd find it they'd find it
people were posting old photos of
construction sites and claiming that
they were just placed there but that's
just internet conjecture Tim you had a
lot but I I saw I saw a lot of
uh stuff on the internet that
would
like January 6th suggests to me that
there were
operatives who took advantage and were
being busting and paid to like aggravate
bad situations so you think the rights
were not people pushing me against covid
I think there were people
yeah I think I think there was that and
I think there were uh aggravators added
to it what about Ferguson no one was
locked in their homes during Ferguson
and there was riots for a long time
Baltimore is another one so Ferguson was
was not this like so in the the 529
George Floyd area some of the worst
rights we've seen in decades that
happened all over the country right and
even at the same time and even in small
cities that people never covered Michael
Tracy famously went down to these cities
that was unpreced like what when Michael
Brown was killed we didn't see writing
to that degree outside of Ferguson it
was just Ferguson which is exactly my
point it could come from the Grassroots
it did not it came from the bathroom
these people Michael Brown was all in
the media too because no no it didn't
come from the Grassroots it came from
agitators and they were paid I don't I
don't know my point is people who turned
onto TVs who have been angry for a very
long time who've been taught that things
are shitty for them that they should be
angry so and so forth saw that they
could go out and manifest their anger
and not only have no consequences but
will be lauded for it I agree so that's
going to encourage a lot of people who
don't have to lose their money
and what I'm saying is the anger was not
because of black lives matter a small
component their anger was because people
were locked in their apartments and
couldn't leave they were becoming
dejected angry and vicious and then they
said hey you're angry at this and they
were like I can go outside and be angry
now and they let it all out being part
of it too yeah I can see that being a
part of it but I think that they I think
that the owners of this country saw an
opportunity to uh burn down small
businesses yes burn down small
businesses and hurt neighborhoods that
they had already targeted anyway with
big corporate fascism you know what it
is I I I've said this before and I want
to say it to get your guys's reaction
far left extremists tore down the
barricades of the White House enduring
70 plus police officers set fire to a
guard post right set fire to St John's
Church Force the president into a bunker
if Donald Trump ordered the police to
stand down he would be president today
ordered the police to stand out on 5 29
2020 if Donald Trump ordered the police
if Bill Barr whoever ordered the police
in D.C to stand down and let the far
left do whatever they want we would not
be talking about January 6. yeah but
would be talking about the torching of
the White House but can is I mean we
would have had the White House torched
there's also some downsides I guess well
so so my point is this and Donald Trump
did does not understand politics
strategy uh culture cultural War
conflict Etc January 6. but police are
taking selfies with people it becomes
the Insurrection if these extremists
burn down St John's Church if they tore
the fences down if they actually
breached the White House
Trump would come out and say we had fear
that innocent people would be harmed if
we if we Advanced and engaged in active
conflict in the streets of DC we just
had the smartest thing to do would be to
save personnel and back off I'm sorry
America far left extremists have
destroyed elements of DC in our
government and that would have Justified
Insurrection act or other actions it
bothers me about January 6th understand
what you're saying yeah like letting
people destroy your home just to get
political to play the victim and be like
Oh nobody live in the capital if right
right so the issue is this Donald Trump
stopped
wait a minute okay let me ask this why
do you think they put up all those uh
barricades and uh barbed wire fences
around D.C all right are you talking
about Ford January 6th or afterwards
after afterwards was as a show of force
to basically to intimidate the the
American people Tim I would agree with
you why was everything facing in and not
out
uh why were the fences facing in towards
the capital I don't think that's true
yeah we like we we're but yeah but like
we we have people who come from DC all
the time that that was not something
anyone ever said and we never saw it the
thing about 529 I would agree with you
more if the media weren't especially at
that time so invested in scripting a
narrative that was only tangentially
related to reality and I think you
remembered everyone hold on let me
finish my point remember it's very
vividly that we were told that Kobe is a
problem you have to stay in your house
and then as soon as these rides hit off
you have to be in the streets protesting
and you're going to be immune from covid
and there's a limit there is a limit
that regular Americans can withstand uh
what I don't think Trump standing down
would have hit that limit I'm sorry I
can't say around the White House and
burn down St John's Church St John's
Church was on fire yeah and they stopped
it if they didn't it would have burned
to the ground and they would have and
then people but then they would have won
and this no no they they they did win so
the issue is this
do you think like the CIA I'll put it
this way I was talking to Occupy Wall
Street activists back 12 years ago and I
said do you think that it's fuel Japan
the Ninja Warrior walks up to the front
Gates and knocks on the emperor's door
and say we hereby demand the emperor
stand down yeah he says I'm the one who
knocks or does the ninja dress like a a
servant sneak in the middle of the night
put a drop a few points into the emperor
and then sneak out the the the in
Warfare it's it's it's it's
surreptitious it's Espionage it's
manipulation it's psychological conflict
and warfare my point is this nobody
should be violent January 6th should
have never happened five to nine should
not have happened my point is whether
you care it has nothing to do with what
should or shouldn't have it has to do
with the logical steps of what does
happen on January 6 people stormed into
the capital the media then showed all
these images and said Insurrection
violence breaking out people fighting
and that terrifies people who don't pay
attention sure if on 529 they did the
same thing and had the police taking
selfies with protesters and letting them
ransack the media can try and that is an
advantage that the establishment has but
there is a a limit St John's Church
being burnt to the ground guard post
being burned the president being locked
in his bunker for for two days they
burned down police stations and no one
cared because they weren't disgusting
that's not true that no one cared black
lives matter went from its highest
approval rating ever to its lowest point
ever following those no one cared to the
point that it would have made a
difference in having Trump reelected I
think with I think you're wrong May 29
it all takes is like an ABC article that
says Trump let them burn the White House
Down and that would have just wrecked
his chances yes there you go yeah I
disagree some people everything bad is
Trump's fault no some people say this
where you're really going to think I'm
crazy but some people say that Trump
signed the thing on December 18th called
continuation I'm sorry some people say a
lot of them military people and believe
I actually stick my nose in military
business that Trump signed a thing on
December 18th continuation of government
and that we are under limited uh martial
law right now already none of that
stuff's true well how do you know
I'll start from the beginning first we
can talk about the actions I believe
that they were all arrested oh no I
believe that they too oh no here we go
here we go they're playing their parts
and that we're going to see military
tribunals I believe it what about
another thousand so the military
tribunals will be public
they already have happened will they be
public by the end of the year yes
and bucks on that too okay so a thousand
dollars that there will be no public
military tribunals no I'm saying there
will be and I'm saying there's not the
bet I'm that's the limited Military
tribunals will be shown by the end of
this year and I'm saying no so will you
bet a thousand dollars no it's only like
four months a thousand bucks on that
okay here we go I love four months I
love Roseanne's optimism
I guess when you have Roseanne money you
can just make these bets
I can show you close this is why I
brought her so I could be rich
and all kinds of stuff that you've never
seen I can show you stuff but I'll tell
you why I believe it because I read The
Art of War and I know that Trump's a
badass and he's not going to let any of
them get away with anything and he
locked up Cheyenne Mountain and they
can't get at it too bad how do you know
that because it's all in the
Declassified documents Cheyenne Mountain
is locked up you say hey
hey Tim Tim pool no let me let me let me
tell you my favorite my favorite thing
ever is uh we are watching a flat Earth
video last week
I'm not saying it's
and my favorite
actually
okay every single Die Hard flat earther
says why can't we travel to Antarctica
you're strange exactly what are you
talking about I know I know he went
there
that's what that thing was going for the
uh Titanic deal it was trying to get to
Antarctica the Pentagon reactivated
Cheyenne Mountain in 2020.
when did Trump lock it up this is where
they have the stars turn the screen for
her so she can see this is where they
have the Stargate what's in it oh that's
where the stars go the headlines so she
could see yeah this is 2012. Joshua's in
it when did Trump lock it down
uh in 21. Trump wasn't president 21.
yeah he was the first week oh right
right right right sorry sorry sorry you
are absolutely right on January 20th
well the first month whatever was
Cheyenne Mountain you can't trust Google
they're controlled opposition this is
like underground research facility
Cheyenne Mountain look it's called the
dumb deep underground military base
the Dom I'm making so much money
[Laughter]
oh I was just in Colorado Springs they
were in probably in those mountains
that's where NORAD command is we drove
by there look under dumb
why is it up
look under dumb no first do Cheyenne
Mountain I I did search for it there's
nothing there nothing comes up and okay
you can make the argument Google's
hiding it but yeah they are okay so when
when people come out and say one Putin
gave remember when Putin gave Trump the
soccer ball when was that no
wake up
remember when they wake up
Google uh Putin gave Trump the soccer
ball oh there we go yeah 2018. aha
well it's five years ago she still got
it shouldn't have better that never
happened no this is it didn't happen
okay
that's what I'm talking about diplomacy
that's over there in Cheyenne Mountain
check that out I've got an article from
Daily Mail says why is the US military
moving back into Stargate base deep
under the Rocky Mountains a decade after
it was abandoned but this is from 2015.
right yeah that's when it started 2015.
there are a lot of things we don't know
about there's a lot of things the
government is doing there's nothing I
don't know about honey I
I can't get in anywhere yeah
one thing is when I'm you're as famous
and damn good looking is me Tiff
all right let's stick my nose in
anybody's business I know how I'm a
grandmother and I have stuck my nose in
the thick of it this time was Michael
Jackson guilty what they accused him of
I'm talking about uh Cheyenne mountains
we're talking about that yeah
I know a lot of military people and I I
do think that the people in America
they're in for a big old wake-up call
back to Michael Jackson four months
dudes are gonna get way worse before
they get better but you better wake up
because wake up wake up and snap out of
it people you've got a lot of work to do
I can imagine deep fake technology
Unleashed on the humans like um there's
stuff called talking plasma that the
military is working on where they'll
triangulate lasers and then create a
ball of plasma to move it around on a
radar looks like a UFO and they can
project sound through the thing can I I
got one sentence Roseanne clone that
hold on one sentence will you please
please please have Ian on your podcast
I'd love to because yes
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at Tim dot com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time